- Good morning Believe Nation.
Todays message is
rest.
Over to you Rick Warren.
(rooster crowing)
♫ I wake up every morning
♫ Entspresso keeps me going
- I take Monday off.
Monday is my Sabbath.
I don't like taking Monday off
because I don't like feeling
that bad on my day off.
(chuckles)
But I find that I need to to recharge
and on Mondays, I am dead to the world.
I do not take calls.
I do not read email.
I do not take text messages.
I sleep in, I get up,
I play around the house
I go to lunch with my wife.
We relax in the afternoon
and Monday evenings we do
family night with our families.
We now have grandkids that are involved.
And we've kept that religiously.
We've kept that faithfully over the years
and it has kept me from burning out
under enormous pressure.
How would you like to pastor a church
where you move the
church building 79 times
in the first 13 years?
I did.
Because land was so expensive
we used 79 different facilities
in the first 13 years.
Some weeks, I'd be in
five different buildings.
Laguna Hills High School
for Sunday morning.
El Toro High School Sunday evening.
A bank building for Wednesday.
Another one on Thursday.
A Saturday night service at another school
and on and on.
We said, "We're the church
if you can figure out
"where we are this week, you get to come."
(congregation laughs)
We said, "We only want our church
"for really intelligent people
"so we keep changing the location."
(congregation laughs)
But that was a lot of frustration.
And I can tell you I
have learned to handle
enormous amounts of stress
and enormous amounts of tension.
But I could not do it
if I didn't rest my body.
If I didn't take my day off.
If I didn't, and don't
call it your day off.
Call it your sabbath.
Call it your day off, you'll fill it
with your honey-do list.
All the stuff that couldn't get done
you try to use it to
catch up on other stuff.
No, it is a day of rest, relaxation
relationships, restoration emotionally.
So you need to rest your body.
- So this is a really
interesting one for me
because my default is to work.
I like to work.
I gain calm and clarity in my work.
Sometimes when I rest too much
like if I go on a beachy vacation
I get really antsy and frustrated.
I want to work.
I hate just sitting down
and being on a beach for a week.
I can handle like one day
but after that, I want to do something.
You know, if Nina's
away for whatever reason
my default is to work.
I'm going to go back and work on projects
because it fills me up and makes me happy.
So this is a harder one for me to answer.
I think the best thing
that I can give you guys
as my advice
is to listen to your body.
Where some days you may need to rest more.
You know, if you're feeling sick
or life is overwhelming
maybe you need to rest more.
And other days, you're able to work more.
You're able to grind it out.
You're able to hustle.
I'm in the camp that believes
that if you are itching for a vacation
if you like, can't wait to get away
to get on that vacation
then something is wrong in your life.
Vacations can add a lot.
The travel can give
you lots of great ideas
can help you grow
and that's a different thing.
But if you're itching
to get away to escape
to just relax and wind down
I feel like there's
something wrong in your life.
That's my belief.
And instead of once or twice a year
escaping from your life
to go do something else
make your life better.
That's my view.
If you're thinking about
how you're spending
your spare time or your free time
are you spending it in escapism?
Are you spending it
watching Big Brother 18
or some reality TV show
or stupid cats fighting each other
or whatever it is?
That's escapism, that's super easy.
That's what most people will do.
They come home and sit on the couch
and plop down and just
escape from their life
by being entertained
or watching the misery
of other peoples lives
which makes them feel
better about themselves.
Is that how you're spending
your time, escapism?
Or are you spending your time
trying to grow and get better?
Like, are you spending
time watching videos?
Are you spending time reading a book?
Are you spending time learning techniques
about your industry?
Are you spending time
learning and growing?
If you are unhappy with your life
audit how you're spending your extra time.
Are you spending your time
escaping the life that you hate
or are you spending your
time growing and building
so that you can build a
better life for yourself?
And for me, a lot of times vacation
most of the time falls into
that category of escapism.
Like I hate my life, I hate what I'm doing
so I need to get away from it
and then I'll come back
and I'll suffer some more
until my next vacation.
But that sucks.
Most people live for the
evenings and weekends
and vacations
as opposed to actually
enjoying and being fulfilled
in the work that you're doing every day.
And so the "rest" one is
a little bit harder for me
again, because I default to work.
And maybe that will change when I'm older.
Maybe I'll feel like I need to rest more
but I also feel like I need
to spend time with my wife.
I need to spend time with my son.
I need to spend time with my family.
And things are always kind of
fighting against each other.
I need to balance my
schedule to make it work
because I'm not just an entrepreneur
and only focus on business.
I also want to be a successful father
and a successful husband
and a successful family man.
And so part of what I do daily
is look at my goals of those categories.
Of family man, leader,
and my own personal health
and making sure I'm spending time
on all three of those every day.
So I don't know that my advice
would be to rest once a week
but I would say listen to your body.
And do what's right for you.
The question of the day today then is
how important is rest for you?
I'm curious.
How much do you rest?
Is it important?
Give me some advice.
Share with Believe Nation.
I'm super curious to hear
what you have to say.
Leave it down in the comments below
and we'll join in the discussion.
I also want to give a quick
shout-out to Dutch Martin.
Dutch, thank you so much for picking
up a copy of my book, Your One Word
it really, really,
really means a lot to me
and I hope you're enjoying it.
Thank you guys so much for watching.
I believe in you.
I hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is.
And I'll see you again tomorrow morning
for another shot of Entspresso.
♫ I wake up every morning
♫ Entspresso keeps me going